David and I were talking this morning
that Hollywood loves to hear about all
the good stuff and we seem to like to
hear about some more of the struggle so
what advice do you have for that 23 year
old that came from Louisiana about the
struggle that I'm sure everybody's gone
through being in the room well uh that's
a good question I feel like ah yeah I
feel like you know if you don't have to
do it you shouldn't you know if it's not
something that you wake up every day and
it's like this is what I want to do then
you know don't you know life is
difficult enough you know it's like if
you're going to suffer for something it
should be something you love and you
know can't live without and if that is
how you feel then you know you just got
to keep fighting you just kind of keep
throwing shoulders and you know get to
develop a tougher skin which is just
part of the process you know what I mean
it's like I wish that there was a nicer
way to say it but it's a tough business
and you know it's it's ruthless in many
ways and the more the more hands-on I
get with the business side of it and the
more it's way worse than I thought it
was you know wait words and that's you
know frustrating but it doesn't negate
the greatness of doing an art that you
love you know what i mean is like if you
break your back making a short film and
that short film never gets into any
festivals and never gets anywhere it's
still something that you made that you
can look at and say this this is my art
that's worth it for me if it's not worth
a view then you shouldn't do it know
anything
so that that overrides any type of
because there's there's different ways
to go people can become bitter for the
business yeah and give up entirely and
that's what and you it's still you fuel
your fuel by wanted to do that next
project I'm filled by wanting to do the
work well now and it's like it's the the
success of the work is also of course
really important and you you can't stop
fighting for that you can't because you
want people to see your work not just
for you but for everyone who's helped
you get there but it's not the end all
be all the end all be all is the work
itself I think and that's when I get
down and I do you know when I'm
struggling with things that are not my
nature you know to really deal with I'm
not the kind of guy that likes to read
contract back to front and you know then
have a very extended debate about you
know each deal point it's one of my
failings but I do that because it's
necessary and nobody else will do it so
but it's really about supporting art
it's like I think about doing another
movie and that's why I can keep doing it
you